we have new information tonight for
those who receive their first covid
vaccine at cashman center
the health district making changes on
how the employment will be set up and
where exactly you will go
joe mohler is live at the health
district office to fully explain joe
well a short time ago the southern
nevada health district announced that if
you did receive your first dose of the
vaccine at cashman center you will be
getting a second dose at the las vegas
convention
center well tonight a lot of people
still have questions about how they'll
be setting up that appointment well
according to the health district
you will be contacted i was a little
confused
where do i go what do i do justin
truescott received the first dose of the
copin 19 vaccine at cashman center
he says he was given a card with some
information regarding the second dose
he told me that on the second shot i
just have to get online and you know
schedule it but on the back of the card
it says remember to come back for your
second shot originally there was set to
be a link on the health district website
on the 25th for second dose appointments
got online on monday no second
appointments i got online tuesday no
second appointment
now the health district says they will
be contacting you for an appointment
true scott was sent an email from the
health district explaining they will
start contacting people
this week if you got the first dose at
cashman you may be going somewhere else
for the second
we'll probably be going from a wednesday
to a sunday
based off of getting our vaccines in on
either monday or tuesday
clark county fire chief john steinbeck
says everything is subject to change at
this point
for now cashman will not be operating
seven days a week due to limited
vaccines
true scott is eager to get his second
dose february 11th they said to get it
or i guess anytime shortly after that
but that's not that far away
again that second dose location will be
the las vegas convention center they say
those appointments will start
on february 2nd we do have more
information on that on our website
eightnewsdown.com
reporting live here at the southern
nevada health district office joe mo 8
news now